Roseanne Barr has one of the most
remarkable life trajectories of anyone
we've ever met and learned more from it
than most people that's for sure she
started at the very bottom then out of
nowhere she created and wrote one of the
most successful sitcoms of all time and
so her career of course she's Roseanne
Barr was thriving and then she made the
mistake of making fun of Barack Obama's
best friend Valerie Jarrett and her
career was completely destroyed they
tried to destroy her personal life too
but she is back she's hard to defeat
she's got a brand new stand-up special
on Fox Nation called Roseanne Barr
cancel this here's part of it
man I had a rough couple of years there
I got fired because basically I racially
uh misgendered somebody I thought was a
white woman
[Applause]
huh
I know I thought that was why it's true
a lot of us thought that in our defense
we're sitting down for a full hour with
Roseanne Barr um it'll be on Fox Nation
but she joins us now on set Roseanne
thank you so much for coming I really
for having me appreciate it so excited
to be on with you well we're going to
get into all the details like we had
dinner last night I was just I was it
was a lot I didn't know about fun the
best delicious absolutely the best
um and we'll get into that but for the
purposes of this segment what is this
special and why is it on Fox Nation what
are you doing and why well it's a kind
of a return to stand up after many years
and they offered me uh you know to come
and do a stand-up special and uh it was
in response to being
you know fired and they came to my
defense and I was like well I thought
about it and uh I was like yeah I need
to have my say I need to answer and
because you know I was kind of not
allowed to even apologize for what
happened I I was just like black bald
and uh you know uh just just totally
canceled from um even commenting on what
happened so I thought well you know
stand up is a great place to come back
and
um say what happened and tell the truth
about it and also to talk about cancel
culture itself and how horrible it is
and how fascist and jokes are a great
great way to uh you know
scorn power especially during Biden's
presidency I love laughing it to scorn
because it deserves to be left to score
and my jokes are so great they're the
most offensive I was talking to my
friends who also were canceled and we
all were saying we made a pact together
when we come back we're going to be even
more offensive than we've ever been
before so my stand-up is more offensive
than I've ever been and I'm so happy
because you've got to be more offensive
when the culture is so offensive that it
makes absolutely no sense that it's
anti-life anti-human
anti-culture anti-citizen you've got to
be so offensive to offend the most
offensive thing that it is on Earth
right now and I think I've done it
that's a very high bar I just I just
want to go one sentence back you have
friends there's a community of people
who've been canceled like you know each
other comedians you know you know
especially comedians because you know uh
like I told you last night I was
terrified when Obama signed the ndaa
thing because I said my God this is an
attack on Comedy and all the comics were
talking about it it's like we will not
be able to say anything now and it's
true and it's funny that I said that on
Twitter and that I was the first
casualty of cancel culture in a large
way but you know uh so many of other
Comics have fallen too and can't find
work and uh you know have no livelihood
because you know unless they you know
are ridiculously sucking up to what the
the left considers to be well the left
has no humor at all so let's be real
they have no sense of humor at all nor
do they have any sense of humor about
themselves like anybody in hour who
can't take a joke about themselves like
the person I mentioned she should have
just laughed it off but instead she
called ABC and demanded that I'd be
fired and so why can't you just laugh at
yourself you know
somebody in power who can't even laugh
at themselves that's a dangerous human
being and this is what they say Obama's
third term so look around I think I was
pretty right on in my uh you know nobody
understood my tweet because they don't
they lack the geopolitical background
even understand it they're like oh she
said Tim you know they're just idiots so
uh but if you can't even laugh at
yourself you're a dangerous human being
and you have power and you have no sense
of humor about yourself that comedians
say that's dangerous
I did not agree more and also the power
differential is fascinating to me so
here you are oh I was gonna say and this
is her third term because she is Obama's
brain when she got you fired so how
exactly and you're one of the most
famous comedians in the world and she
got you fired from your job and
humiliated and kind of overturned your
wife she had the power to do that so how
is it that she has the right to be
offended by what you know like she
shouldn't be offended she's in power I
know because they never these people
they they're always the victim they
bully bully bully bully and then when
they're called on being a bully because
it was me then they're the victim the
endless bully victim thing it's two
sides of the same coin and they're
trying to turn our entire culture into
bully bully victim and it's just not
going to work and uh my jokes are kind
of to that effect why are we calling
these people victims that are actually
bullies yes and way more powerful than
we are powerful enough to get Roseanne
Barr fired from her TV show yeah and
they enjoyed oh my God they enjoyed
doing it they really enjoyed it yeah
they enjoy that they do
enjoy sticking well you were talking
about the whole uh
uh climate culture religion they
they inflicting pain oh I I'm sure they
sit there and go yeah we're gonna cut
you know like old people can't get their
pain meds I hear this all the time as my
mom's old they they deny old people in
their 80s pain meds they like that they
like inflicting because you know it's
basically it's like it is fascist and
Nazi they do experiments on captive
populations no different and it's
disgusting and then we're supposed to
see that as Progressive it's not it's
anything but I just I just wanted to say
it I'm I'm not going to let them have
the last word not on me I'll be fighting
in my uh depends on a on a Dem I don't
care I'm never going to give up they're
not going to get me okay anybody who
just heard what you said will be waiting
for the full hour in for your special
amazing Roseanne Barr thank you the fox
station stand up special is called
Roseanne Barr cancel this it is out
Monday February 13th and as we said
we're going to speak with her for a full
hour that will appear soon on Fox Nation
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight